A federal
judge overseeing the former president's
indictment on election
interference has denied his attempt
to dismiss charges
based on a claim
of presidential immunity.
At one point in her ruling,
the judge, Tanya
Chutkan, writes,
quote, Defendants for your service
as commander in chief
do not bestow on him
the divine
right of kings
to evade the criminal accountability
that governs his fellow citizens.
This decision comes
the same day as another setback
for the former president
in federal court in Washington.
A three judge appeals court
panel decided
he can be sued in
civil court related to his actions
during the January 6
riot at the Capitol.
The decision was unanimous
to distinguish
between campaign speech
and official actions of a president.
It's a victory for the Capitol
Police and lawmakers behind
three separate cases
affected by the decision,
plus others
who may now seek civil damages as well.
Perspective on all this
from CNN political analysts
Maggie Haberman, senior
political correspondent
for The New York Times,
also the author of Confidence Man
The Making of Donald Trump
and the Breaking of America.
Also, Caroline Polisi, she's White House.
She's, excuse me,
a white collar criminal defense attorney.
She's also a lecturer
at Columbia Law School.
How big, Maggie,
of a blow to the former
president is this?
Look, it was always a long shot
that this is going to go through
or the shutdown
was going to roll on his side.
She's made very clear in previous rulings
how she views some of the claims
that Trump has been making
or his lawyers have been making.
But what this does does do
is it starts the clock on an appeal
that they are going to have
go through the courts,
possibly go up to the Supreme Court.
No one knows how the
Supreme Court will rule
if they will even take it up.
They don't have to.
They have generally not sided
with Trump on any of his election
related issues.
They obviously have on other issues.
If they send this back
or if they rule against him.
The clock then starts on the trial.
But this buys time for his team.
So this is not a surprising ruling,
but it is a very, very lengthy ruling.
And it refers to the Nixon pardon.
It refers to a number of things
that counter
what Trump's team is arguing.
Carolina, what stood out to you
in these rulings?
Yeah, I think, look, earlier today
when the D.C.
Circuit came out with the ruling
with respect to the civil context,
that was an easier bar to meet.
The presidential immunity is really,
you know,
a thing that has been recognized
by the Supreme Court
since Nixon versus Fitzgerald.
Trump was trying to push it
further in the criminal context.
Not surprising that check in waited,
I think, for
sort of her superiors
to come out with
with the ruling this afternoon.
And then immediately I agree with Maggie.
I think she's
she wants to keep that March
4th trial date.
This is the one thing
that could potentially
throw a wrench in those plans
if the case is somehow stayed
pending an appeal.
Certainly,
I think he certainly will appeal
this ruling as well as the D.C.
Circuit ruling.
And I think it is right for
Supreme Court review.
So do you think it's likely
it would be stayed?
You know,
just as Maggie was saying,
you never know
what the Supreme Court is going to do.
They can take it.
They cannot they could stay.
They could not.
But I think that that is sort of
the question mark here
with respect to that.
It's looking like more and more like
that's going to be the only trial
that will sort of get in under the gun
before the election.
Is it clear to you, Maggie,
what other
arguments the president might make to try
to get this thrown out?
I think this was a big one.
I think if I think getting it thrown out
is going to be very, very hard.
This was really
if this was the shot, it's possible
someone was suggesting to me today
that the Supreme Court
could take up the gag order issue
that seems a little less
likely than this one,
just because this is
a presidential power issue
and it's a little broader
that the other one is specific
to Trump as a defendant.
I think this is it.
In terms of their shot
of getting it thrown out entirely.
Next up becomes just,
you know, trying for an acquittal
or trying for a hung jury
or trying that those are their best hope.
This is this is a case that being tried
in D.C., Trump's allies and advisers
think is unlikely to go his way
just based on the events
and based on what the jury pool will be.
But that's down the road.
There was also, Maggie,
the pretrial hearing in the Georgia
election case, which stood out either.
Well, it was interesting
listening to this argument
that the trial ought to start.
I think it was
there was some suggestion
it should start in 2029
or something like that.
I mean, well, well,
well down the road,
what you've heard over
and over again from the Trump lawyers
is there's such a volume of discovery.
This is such an exotic case.
And they've said this in various ones.
We need time to go through everything
for discovery.
We need time to look at the evidence
in the march.
A lot of the documents case,
there are clearance issues there.
There actually are on the January
six case, too,
although it's a little less so
that it doesn't surprise me
that they're talking about a delay.
A delay of that much
was surprising to me.
And I would be mostly surprised
if it works in Georgia.
The president's attorneys are arguing
that this violates Trump's
free speech rights.
Yeah,
And they by the way,
they made that argument today
in the check in motion as well,
which which she denied.
But the 2029 date, you know,
that was under the scenario in which
the judge asked
Trump lawyers, well, what would happen
if he were to be elected president?
Essentially,
it would stop the clock on
that that time to prosecute.
But I have a different perspective
because I'm the defense attorney.
I think the August 2024 date
is a bit aggressive.
There are
there's a backlog
in the criminal in Fulton County, Georgia
Criminal Court.
And, you know, it cuts both ways.
Any criminal defendant
shouldn't be above the law.
I think finally,
Wallace is trying
to push this case through.
She wants to get it in
before the election.
I think it's pretty apparent. Yeah.
Which of these cases
do you think the former president
is most concerned about?
I think he's concerned
about all of them, honestly.
I think that he's more concerned
about the federal ones.
The the documents case
in particular concerns him,
except for the judge in that case,
which is one of his own appointees.
And the fact that it's a more favorable
jury pool just based on the counties
around the courthouse.
The January six case angers him
for a variety of reasons.
And you can see it when he talks
about the election, relates to
an event that he considered humiliating,
which is having to leave the White House.
And so I think all of these things
tie together.
He's angry about the Manhattan indictment
for different reasons,
and there's no case
that makes him feel good here.
They're all they're all bad,
but they are most
they're most concerned right now
about the January 6th one
because they think that's the one
that's likely.
It's nice to me
the humiliation is having
to leave the White House
as opposed to the humiliation
of having his supporters
break into the Congress.
And we've heard him defend that.
We've heard him defend that.
So that is not something
that I have heard him sound
any any concession of shame
about publicly to the point
about fairness versus
a speedy trial, though,
I think that you are going to hear that
over and over again.
And it is the one place
or a place where the Trump team
has a legitimate point
about the fact that Trump does
have the same rights
as any other defendant.
Caroline, thanks so much.
Maggie Haberman.